here with reaction is professor of
business and economics at the king's
college in manhattan
fox news contributor and former neighbor
of mine when we were in fifth grade
brian bremberg and fox business
contributor phil flynn brian great to
see you adding this all up
it almost makes it makes me feel like
we're here we are back to never let a
crisis go to waste you're going to feel
the pain we don't have the answer but
the answer is more pain to this perfect
green future you're just going to have
to wait a while for it and suffer in the
process
this is a problem pete it doesn't add up
the president is doubling down on the
wrong hand we have seen this play out
before that's what we've watched in
europe for the better part of two
decades they have tried to double down
on green energy and it left them
dependent on a dictator
we're going to end up in the exact same
kind of spot if we keep going down the
green religion path that he's going down
a religion that demands sacrifice isn't
interested in growth isn't interested in
getting wealthier so we can innovate
cleaner technologies it wants americans
to pay up this is the wrong approach
phil can give you all the numbers pete
but at this point the president
completely lacks any strategic direction
on helping americans
one gets the impression and you can see
this in the polls americans think this
one gets the impression the president
likes these higher prices because he
doesn't want to let this crisis go to
waste and he's willing to put it on the
backs of american families
it's amazing phil give me those numbers
because there are alternatives in ways
we could find uh the energy resources
required to both support ourselves and
get back to energy independence and
energy dominance but also support europe
as it seeks to cut itself off from
russia as well are we going to do any of
those things
yeah we should absolutely i mean we have
enough uh natural gas in the ground to
supply
the us and europe maybe for a hundred to
two hundred years and with new
technologies and innovation even more
than that but what i find amazing about
this pete here here is president biden
uh you know saying you know he's going
to double down on his green energy
policy but then when they get into
trouble they call on the u.s energy
industry to save their uh best sides
right what's that all about it's like
hey we're going to send you good
old-fashioned american-made lng from
america to europe to save the day well
who made that it was the u.s energy
industry mostly done on private lands
because you can't get a federal lease
these days you know and you know i
wonder if they call the energy companies
are they going to buy this energy and
then give it to europe or you know are
they going to dictate who we sell this
to listen the u.s energy industry is
more than ready and willing to grow
their business so they can do this in
the future but you're not with joe biden
in office when every step of the way
they get in their way of doing what they
want to do
yeah brian i don't know if you heard the
previous segment but uh i was talking to
matt schlapp and he said i said what do
we do he said wait three years uh and
and he was sort of joking but that's the
feeling a lot of americans have right
now is is it doesn't feel like uh the
the the cavalry is coming so if you if
we know oil and gas and nuclear if we
would ever explore that but if we knew
actual oil and gas independence is
something we could do
and we're not going to do it
then what happens for the next three
years for americans
well we keep paying up pete i mean
that's the problem that's why people are
so pessimistic about their economic
situation right now they're not
pessimistic because they think the
american economy can't be great they're
pessimistic because they've got a
president who has no plan for getting
out of this he has a plan for digging
deeper into this we need some hope we
need a president to go out on american
soil and speak to american oil and gas
producers and say we are doubling down
on your production we are doubling down
on your pipelines we are going to become
independent not just for our sake
but for the sake of the world europe
depends on this frankly they need a
rescue right now and the only country on
planet earth that can do that is the
united states of america but we've got
to have a president because nobody
believes that he wants to see this
industry thrive the banks don't believe
it the producers don't believe it the
pipeline infrastructure guys don't
believe it he has got to go out there
and say i'm going to stand up to
everybody in this country who's been
telling me to double down on green
energy and instead i'm gonna double down
on american production of oil and gas
that's it pete otherwise it's three
years of the same thing you've seen for
the last three months
phil on the campaign trail joe biden
said repeatedly that he wanted to end
fossil fuels he was going after the oil
and gas industry he was going after
fracking he's going after energy
let's just say if it a terrible green
new deal world he and his leftist
friends got what they wanted in the
green new deal and their climate agenda
what would that do to what we're what
we're actually facing right now as a
country what would that actually mean
pete we would look at these as a good
old days of cheap energy prices you know
they're their plans you know if you do
the math on what they're trying to
accomplish it's similar to what's
happening in europe and europe is only a
preview of what's going to happen i mean
natural gas
at the peak got to the equivalent of 600
a barrel crude oil this year you know
now you can imagine you know gasoline
prices in california are already close
to seven dollars a gallon with oil yet
104 could you imagine what they would be
if oil prices were up to 600 so this is
this is just craziness listen at the end
of the day when we're talking about the
green energy deal we need to pull back
from this because what it is uh it is a
deal that will undermine the us economy
it will take money from the poor and
give it to the green energy rich this
isn't even about you know cleaning the
environment because if you really go
through these green energy things you
know
the united states has actually reduced
greenhouse gas emissions better than
anybody in the paris climate accord
and as it pertains to energy dominance
it was ronald reagan in the 80s who
warned germany if you depend on soviet
energy if you approve nordstrom one
you're going to be beholden to them
someday in the future here we are trump
warned of the same thing
uh biden
biden didn't and here we are that's why
many people including my co-host on fox
and friends weekend rachel campos stuff
he calls this the green new deal war and
i think it's uh it's pretty tough to
refute that at this point brian and phil
thank you so much for your time
appreciate it